[Music]
oh look
if it wasn't for Lori Strode I don't
think I'd be standing here with you
today it was the same most singular
moment of my professional life these
days Jamie Lee Curtis loves her
Halloween Roots but she didn't always
embrace them horror films I don't see
anything that wrong I really don't I
don't like the critics weren't always
fans either everybody put me down
because they called me an exploitive
actress they said that I was promoting
violence against women when in all these
films I never took off my clothes I
played the girl next door the one who
fought back I've played three
prostitutes and I've taken off my
clothes twice but now I'm Legit
interestingly so how did Jamie Lee go
from scaredy cat to scream Queen
I think it's great as an actress your
your joy is when an audience identifies
with you and your characters and goes
out to see you now if horror films have
given me what people have called or
described as a cult status I can't
say that that's bad how's that bad
that's great she starred in seven
Halloween movies as Lori Strode since
1978 including Halloween ends released
just this month killed him come and get
me mother
it's cool that you're taking this woman
and saying all right
enough she on the surface has sort of
been coping and underneath she's just
out of her mind
you in Hell she's never afraid I think
that there's something very important
about saying
that you stop running and you turn back
and you face your demons goodbye Michael
[Music]
I'm standing on the movie set of a movie
I made 40 years ago wow and I'm playing
the same character she isn't a badass
woman I think strength is intelligence
and I think what you're going to watch
her do is use her intelligence
to
win and that's going to be stronger than
any muscle Lori Strode simply represents
an innocent girl who had her life
brutalized by a monster I'm very proud
that my legacy as a human being as an
actor is that
I was Lori Strode the girl who never
gave up and I think that's a legacy
of perseverance and courage after all
horror is in Jamie's blood her mom Janet
Lee became an icon after she starred in
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho
the scariest movie ever made is probably
psycho and so
obviously the connection between us is
great I have great respect for her as an
actress Janet died in 2004 and Jaime
found a special way to honor her seven
years later at the premiere of Halloween
kills I thought
maybe I need a
little bloody uh
shower curtain
[Music]